Elton John is in the film,
what was it like working with the great Elton John?
Ah, well it was heaven really.
[Conan] Yeah
Wasn't it, wasn't it?
[Conan] Anyone can chime in on this one.
Yeah.
Like he's the, he's the--- What are we allowed to say?
I don't know
but Elton John's one of those people
that I hadn't actually like considered he's
a real person until I met him. (audience laughing)
Do you know what I mean?
All of a sudden he's there
and it's oh no you are actually a human being
'cause he's such an icon,
He's so famous, he's so famous.
Yeah, and it was lovely
and he's so good in the movie.
He's so, so good.
He's extraordinary in the movie
and he's every bit a real person.
I mean you know,
there's the larger than life
'cause we've seen him as a chicken
and Donald Duck and-- (audience laughing)
[Conan] Yeah, yeah.
And the songs have gone through
just about every era of my life.
[Conan] Yes.
And then you just get this really
sweet guy who's an extraordinary pro,
he's a very, very good actor.
And I think there's a serious
danger he will steal the movie.
Ah I believe there's was a moment
when his dressing room was unattended
and you visited it, is that true?
I don't think anyone else in the cast knows that,
I don't normally try on other people's clothes
when they're not there. (people laughing)
Except for the, except for
Except (beeping)
Except (beeping) in Channing's case.
(people laughing)
He just came and said, this is my last day
and whipped it out of my hand.
(people laughing)
No, this is not Channing anymore,
this is Elton,
it was hanging there, tantalizing.
(audience laughing)
Moving on from the Channing bit.
Yes, yes, I'm gonna move on
you filthy, filthy man.